walk anywhere today and you'll see Apple
earpods dangling out of people's ears
these cordless earbuds have become a
status symbol I mean who needs to
actually learn to code when you can just
pop into earbuds and bam you now work in
tech although this year butts currently
need to be taken out to charge Apple is
accelerating wireless charging so what
would happen if you never took off your
ear pods first you need to figure out a
way to make them stick in your ears
this is because a man named Ben's who
recently fell asleep with his ear pods
in and woke up with one beeping from his
stomach he'd actually swallowed it in
his sleep
I mean this is anecdotal evidence that
amazingly air pods kid withstand stomach
acid which has a mighty pH of 1.7 he ran
to the doctor who told him to just wait
the air pod made its way through his
intestines colon and finally out his
anus in fact the digestive system was so
effective in differentiating the air pod
from actual nutrients that the headphone
came out fully intact and continued to
work so next time you see someone with
air pods on the street just remember
they could have come out of there but
many people think that leaving air pods
and would cause a buildup of earwax but
this is actually not true earwax is
produced when objects are put in and out
of your ear like a q-tip actually here's
a hot q-tip don't use q-tips they cause
earwax in this hypothetical a believing
the air pods in your ear and never
taking them out so a buildup of earwax
would not be an issue but what would be
an issue is your here we spend most of
our lives in air which is a sound
transmitting medium because of this our
ears evolved into something we now call
a transducer a transducer is anything
that changes energy from one form to
another vibrating objects produce energy
in the form of sound waves when a sound
wave reaches your ear it now causes your
eardrum to physically vibrate this
physical vibration moves hairs in your
ear which result in neural electrical
signals that are translated to your
brain this is how you hear anything
including whatever is coming out of your
ear pots such as music or season one of
our podcast sidenote streaming wherever
you get your podcasts in total this
process involves your external ear
middle ear in
your brainstem and brain but when
looking at the type of damage caused by
leaving any type of headphone on forever
we need to focus on your inner ear noise
induced hearing loss is something
everyone who wears headphones should be
thinking about it is one of the most
common forms of acquired hearing
impairment children teenagers and adults
who listen to headphones for long
durations of time are at a significant
risk of hearing loss one study found
listening to your air pods for as little
as seven hours a week can cause hearing
loss this is super intense as I listened
for way longer than that I'm obsessed
with music but there are some other
studies that had less drastic results
the US National Institute for
Occupational Safety and Health okay big
name much say the maximum exposure our
ears can take without risk is eight
hours a day of sound at 85 a weighted
decibels a weighted decibels which from
now on we were just gonna call decibels
is a measurement of sound pressure in
regards to the human ear eight hours
seems like a lot of time to be wearing
headphones daily but a survey found that
seventeen to twenty five percent of
people actually felt they listened to
their headphones for longer than eight
hours a day and when randomly stopping
people out of translation in Sweden
another study found that 46 percent of
participants were exceeding 85 decibels
of sound from their headphones this
meant their ears were at risk air pots
can reach as high as 101 decibels to a
hundred and thirty nine decibels
depending on which lab was doing the
testing so it's important that no matter
how long you're wearing your ear pods
you keep the volume lower than 75
percent leaving your air pods in for any
extended period of time can cause an
overexposure to sound which damages the
cochlea the outer hair cells and the
stree avascular of the inner ear this is
why many new studies conclude the more
you listen to any type of headphone the
more likely you are to have permanent
hearing loss but even worse than all of
this is that after a week of not
removing your ear pods you would have an
infection at the point when you pop
those earbuds in for eternity any dirt
or moisture in your ear canal would get
stuck moisture and dirt makes bacteria
feel good therefore they will
proliferate a buildup of bacteria in
your ear causes inflammation and
infection the air pods blocking airflow
in and out of your ear means more
humidity and increased temperatures
this makes the bacteria you'll even
happier and the infection even worse
within two weeks of leaving your air
pods in you would likely have a
granuloma and potentially burst your
eardrum so even though air Potts make it
so you can absolutely demolish more
meetings shoot off emails soups fast and
appear rich it is important to take them
out daily listen to them at an
appropriate volume and don't sleep with
them in unless of course you are looking
for a wittle late-night snack now that
you know if you keep your ear pods low
and you take them out to charge they're
safe to use would you ever use air pod
no because I'm android for life okay
awkward great that's funny giving air
buds they are now thanks for watching if
you're interested in more ear stuff we
actually have a really popular ear test
video to figure out how old your ears
are they even talked about it on modern
family back in the days I said so on
make sure you like and subscribe and
we'll see you next week